assuming 10 plus million dollars sitting
in the bank today maybe thanks to Layla
closer to 15 I'm guessing oh way more
than that
cash okay
I sold three companies last year and a
house and two cars I sold everything
last year you're looking at what's
happening predicting there's inflated
pricings I mean a lot of people are
really afraid of inflation and I think
that's super warranted like looking at
Uncle Warren right he's got 150 billion
in cash sitting right now he's not
worried about it I'm like you see more
Cycles than I have so he's got 25 of his
entire company value sitting in cash I
mean to be clear it's not working for
you I mean it's earning a tiny bit of
Interest compared to what you could have
in stocks or investment properties so a
little inflation's not going to kill me
but like when you look at the Nast actor
in the crash in whatever 0-1 or whatever
the year was it dropped by 78 that would
be significant it would be significant
just given the timing I'm willing to
wait a little bit and see what's going
on and so that is why I have more cash
than I probably would know